a man who advertises his products on Fox
News says specifically that his company
advertises on Fox News because the
viewers are gullible and stupid you've
probably seen those funny infomercial
like television ads sometimes the 30
seconds long sometimes they're a minute
long that a lot of them are on daytime
television or really late at night
usually not so much in primetime it's
often like a kitchen device or some
super specialized piece of clothing that
solve some minor problem that's
portrayed as like a life change in
Cataclysm in the ad a lot of times they
film the before you had the product part
in black and white with sad music and
people are frowning and then the after
you bought the product part is usually
in color and the actors are really happy
and upbeat all of a sudden you ever see
a compilation video I had all those
before you had this it's the best and
there's a company that advertises on Fox
News called Scott evaced
it's a vest that has a lot of internal
pockets - apparently solve the problem
of being unable to carry around all your
things when you're just walking around
in the world here's their 30-second ad
just to give you an idea of what we're
talking about my name is Scott Jordan my
problem I had tons of stuff to carry but
no easy way to do it
so I started Scottevest at Scottevest we
make great-looking clothing with tons of
hidden pockets and unique features now
you can carry all your stuff hands-free
while looking great never worry about
misplacing anything ever again
the uses are endless Scottevest will
change your life try it out visit
Scottevest comm right now and browse
dozens of styles for both men and women
right so it turns out that Breitbart of
all places Breitbart will not tolerate
criticism of Fox News apparently and
they spotted that CEO or founder former
former CEO and founder Scott Jordan
posted on his personal Facebook post I
love meeting new people that recognize
me and my company from our television
commercials I'm on the ski lift and the
following exchange just happened and
happens often so I asked what network
they saw me on invariably people say Fox
News I laugh to myself and tell them
that we primarily advertise on Fox
because we find their viewership to be
extremely gullible and much easier to
sell than other networks the look on
their face at that time is priceless I
am not kidding you I get to tell them
they are effing idiots while getting
rich off of them now in response to
Jordan's post Scottevest corporation put
out a statement calling the remarks
offensive and inexcusable and he ended
up issuing an apology where he said
quote or rather the statement from
Scottevest said the recent offensive and
inexcusable social media post by Scott
Jordan does not reflect the views of
Scott Eve s he stepped down last year
from management and he's not even
involved and then he has since deleted
his Facebook and Twitter accounts and
published an apology on medium this is
so funny for multiple reasons number one
it's funny because it's obviously true
there's no doubt that the reason Alex
Jones sells garbage supplements that
will make you vital or whatever the
reason he sells it is because he has an
audience that disproportionately likely
to buy that crap the reason Glenn Beck
was associated with the Gold Line scam
where they would say it's good to have
gold financially but instead of just
selling you gold they would sell you
collectible coins that have just an
astronomically inflated value the reason
even that gwyneth paltrow pseudoscience
nonsense on her goop website that
probably appeals to the sort of anti
vaccine type crowd these are markets
that you can market to more easily and
Fox News is along those lines so it's
completely true what he says but then
it's obvious that someone from the
company called them and they were like
listen you still make money off of this
what you're doing is really not good for
us you've got to put out an apology and
he puts one out but obviously he still
thinks this right like who reads the
fact that he apologizes Oh Scott Jordan
doesn't think that the Fox News viewers
are gullible and stupid anymore
he knows that they are because they've
got sales data and they know they do way
better on Fox News for this nonsense
product yeah really dumb move on his
part though especially because these are
your business partners I mean you you
pay them to advertise your products
right it even though you're not directly
involved in the company you're still
getting those kickback yeah
and you're also insulting the people who
buy your product doesn't really make
much sense you're insulting everybody
and it maybe he thought if it went on
his personal Facebook site it would
never become widely known but it's funny
because it's true and it also by the way
relates to why I turned down offers to
advertise products like a recent one was
these chocolate energy and mental
clarity bites that had you know ginkgo
and who knows what else that that that
improve your brain function and all this
stuff and I immediately say I don't
believe the claims and neither will our
audience now if if I was immoral I would
say I think the product is BS but I
think you're gonna trick our audience I
know the reason we have brilliant org is
an advertiser and not brain function
chocolate energy bytes is because I also
have some sense and we've surveyed our
audience and understand something about
about who they are as well yeah but
David the Scottevest makes it so that
you can carry all your stuff on you yeah
as you go around from place to place you
don't have to wear a backpack and I mean
you have to wear the same article of
clothing every day yeah you'll get used
to it I'll have to walk around looking
like Steve Irwin for the rest of my life
in order to carry two firearms and three
laptops inside my best in case I ever
need that what a crazy product right I
mean I guess if I was camping I could
imagine maybe buying it or like for
hiking or something like that I don't
know I don't know I don't think you
don't think you would buy it no matter
what the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad